just like every first overall choice
that there is he's like if you call me
you call cuz he has leverage taking a
page from Joe borrow my buddy Adam
Schefter how are you Adam
oh what's going on bud how are you wait
right for next week yeah buddy
we're going what is what leverage does
Joe Borough have what's he talking about
Adam let's get right into it what in the
world is he talking about good leverage
here at the situation where basically
you've got a situation where he can
decide that I'm going to make life tough
for Cincinnati if it wanted to do this
right if he wanted to do that if that
was a rocky decides to go and so I guess
it didn't seem because there are many
players like you go where your picks and
where you're told to go and he would
have the option the situation of I guess
going Eli Manning going John Elway on
the Bengals if he doesn't like what he
hears and he doesn't like what he sees
and it goes a certain route right that
would be his leverage but I don't think
he's ready to go nuclear yet I think
he's reserving the right to change mind
let me say this to you a couple of
things keep in mind yes sir he's sort of
the exaction era here but first of all
his girlfriend's from Cincinnati his
back his brothers played with AC Joe
Burrus father I believe there's a
connection between Zack Taylor's family
and Joe burrows family and so he's just
not committing to say okay
Bengals take me I'm all good I want to
go to Cincinnati I want to be he may get
there and it may not but but I guess
he's got the right to make up his mind
about what he wants to do and not want
to do right and and I guess that's the
leverage that you're looking for right
now is this a story
we just pride in time between now and
the first night of the first pick in Las
Vegas or is there some smoke here do you
think Adam I I think it's too early to
savor it
right now rich I mean we're gonna wonder
about it and when you get statements
like that you'll wonder about it mm-hmm
but but I don't know if it's going to
develop into one or not let's put this
way it bears watching how about that
about the best I could tell you on
February night Darrell watch borough
watches on Adam Schefter here on the
Rich Eisen show okay then let's do some
more quick hitters involving the combine
and to his hip and he got the best
possible news easy could get apparently
from his latest medical report Armando
cigarro saying that there's some signs
that maybe Justin Herbert would be the
apple of the dolphins eye I read that to
say that the Lions might be holding the
Dolphins up for the number three overall
pick in Detroit I wonder what you're
hearing or thinking about this whole
scenario with - and the quarterbacks
first of all if the Dolphins light
Justin Harbor or two or more than like
Joe burrows over we really know that
right now you really know that and so
I'm skeptical of anything I hear at this
time of the year I think it's a lot of
noise - the time being when the teams
haven't even gone any when the workouts
haven't begun when we're entering into
the offices I guess again
the Dolphins have the leverage and the
ammo to do what they want in this
particular draft process right and so
there's a certain quarterback that they
feel like they have to have they can
figure out a way to go get them I just I
don't know yet and I don't know what
they know yet we know which guy that is
at this point in time and we'll be a lot
of smoke and a lot of speculation here I
think rich and I'm not trying to avoid
your questions this I think that we're
looking for answers right now to a lot
of questions that are really interesting
and are going to be really interesting
for the next two months but it's hard to
say to you on sub one
oh yes rich your boys gonna hold out
easier demand and yes the dolphins are
gonna be angling to move up to get to up
like I just don't think it's that black
and white on this day just yet like
where we can give you draw answers I
wish I could I can't no I understand I'm
just trying to see if you if what what
they what the ear to the ground might
come up with Adam Schefter here on the
Rich Eisen show what where does things
with Brady stand right now as best you
can tell between Brady and the Patriots
and the conversations that need to
happen over the next two to three weeks
this is gonna be the most initially
inflection you'll see I know we'll say
this if you'll allow me last week you
have kind enough to come on my podcast
yes sir and this week Jeff Jeff darling
take care of my podcast intelligent is a
lot more connected to that particular
situation and I think a lot of people
realize and in talking with him
yesterday and my eyes were open to this
I mean I always thought this was
possible but I got even more of
Internet's more possible Jeff Johnson
basically I'm a handicap that tightens
as the favorite right now which I was
like whew okay I knew that he was an
option but he made it out to be more of
an option that I realized it to be in
his mind to rank the teams right now
would be Tennessee Las Vegas in New
England and and I thought that was and
and and and his explanation of things on
the podcast was very interesting mmm-hmm
and so my takeaway from that was I think
we all need to pay a little bit more
attention to Tennessee here than we
thought and Tennessee is more viable as
a potential Tom Brady destination that
we thought and Tennessee I expect to be
in the mix Las Vegas I expect to be in
the mix I think the Chargers lips.i to
be in the mix I don't know if they'll be
able to get it done and and then of
course the question is does you get back
to doing another real interesting one I
tend to see is this they have Ryan
Tannehill yep and if you franchise Ryan
Tannehill
well then it's very hard to go get Tom
Brady
okay yeah I don't think you do that but
do you take the risk of not franchising
a guy played like a franchise
quarterback last year and trying to get
Tom Brady running the risk that you
could lose both for you go ahead and
franchise Tannehill and remove the brady
option off the table when it certainly
sounds like it's a possibility and I'll
leave the the meat and potatoes on on
why the Titans are a favorite in Jeff
Darlington his mind as a tease for
people to go to the item shefter podcast
because I know I know how this whole
thing works and I and I'd love and
appreciate you and I enjoyed being on
the item shefter podcast last week
you're welcome so do we put Phillip in
in Indianapolis do we draw that line or
is Tampa an option because Phillip and
the family now lives in Florida in that
area what do you got for me on that
front Adam well I think there it is very
easy to make the connection in
Indianapolis okay Frank like work with
look rivers on the Chargers Knicks
Arianny that Colts offensive coordinator
who's very good working with Phillip
Rivers on the Chargers he knows the
offense would fit right in it'll be a
seamless transition they have a team
talented in the form with just about
anybody at quarterback so yeah I think
there's smoke there now that doesn't
mean Phillip Rivers lines up in
Indianapolis but I expect them to be
interested I expect him to be interested
and we'll see whether or not they get a
deal work out all right and then let me
just knock a few rocks over on the
Raiders front here in a few minutes I
have with you left Brady to the Raiders
I mean what would that mean with Derek
Carr I mean what are the financial
ramifications of that best you can tell
off the top of your head that makes it
sound viable to you potentially Adam
no I think it's just that that decision
you make I think they can make it work
with their car and in all season that's
where we have I think you would agree
the most intriguing offseason the
quarterback movements that we were add
maybe so we're not paying a lot of close
attention to Derek Carr and Cam Newton
and some of these other guys who could
back there in Jameis to Jameis book you
know that yeah we all know his contracts
up great and and I don't think it's a
slam dunk that he's back in Tennessee
and Tampa Bay by any stretch of the
imagination right so what happens if
he's not back in Tampa where's he going
now I'll just say I always remember Jon
Gruden being a big campus Winston's man
from our production meetings with him
back when he was with the SPN and so you
wonder would they have any interest in
Jameis Winston that that would seem to
make sense to me uh based on how he felt
but there's an awful lot of Raider
quarterback talk just a lot of talk like
that that just gets your antenna up and
makes you wonder what is the future with
Derek Carr they're in open over Las
Vegas all right last one for you this is
the collective bargain agreement 17
games being discussed how real is it and
is it possible that the the NFL and the
Players Association do in fact hammer
that out in time for a new league year
and the next month but what are you
hearing on that front and
yeah I believe there's a real chance
that happening rich I believe that when
the CBA gets done I don't know how
they'll do it I don't know when they'll
do it but I believe that when the new
CBA gets done
it'll be 17 game season that that's what
I believe will be the case in the end
and you know the NFL very well the NFL
usually gets what it wants and so the
NFL wants 17 games and so I expect the
NFL to get 17 games and if I had to bet
I would bet they hammer out that you
know at some point in the next month if
they don't obviously it'll be a long
wait
maybe until the following summer a year
from this summer mm-hm but again I just
go back to at statement what the NFL
wants the NFL usually more often than
not gets the end of a walk for 17 games
it wants the deal done and somehow I
just think the NFL will push to get this
done in the next month and it will be a
17-game season and then as he goes out
the door Brockman I want to bring this
up to you Adam
Brockman my boy here yesterday brought
up the fact that if the 17 game schedule
hits and you had another bye week then
the NFL gets what it's been looking for
for a long time which is the Super Bowl
on President's Day weekend and a
national holiday the day after the Super
Bowl
Brockman says the NFL should call the
NBA and say hey this is what we're doing
and give them a heads up because it's
gonna screw over their all-star game do
you think the NFL does that Adam just
give the NBA a heads up just to let them
know you had give them a common courtesy
that this is what's going to happen yes
correct that's what I told him yesterday
he's like what about the common courtesy
a common courtesy an organization that
would just clean out your office and
send your belongings Adam Schefter for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app